our staff all the people who work for us
in 2018 Robin revealed some incredible
things
most of them involved weird sex stuff of
course our perverted limo driver Ronnie
limo driver was the worst of the bunch
we learned a lot more about Ronnie this
year yeah here's the moment Ronnie
admitted he had taken her dildo up his
[ __ ] and we were all kind of shocked
did you ever have a girl [ __ ]
massaged your prostate no course not
once you have a guy put a cup what do
you mean that Y same thing I'm not gay
and it's not the right channel wait a
minute why don't you have a woman put a
strap-on on him but and stimulate that
ya pegging
[Laughter]
everybody loved that Robin there's a
knock on our door why you saying [ __ ]
you I watched him grow and I watched his
[ __ ] grow mm as long as we're doing
year-in-review in 2018 we met you mrs.
Mondt and I gotta say was one of my
highlights right Robin we loved her in
the month of the sex and having anal at
a young age is considered a great thing
he's a prodigy Ronnie takes after his
father you this month
ulis so all the money in the air you
would peg with him what would you put in
Ronnie unis amongst the old kind of
style you're telling me Ronnies dad
could take that big object up his ass
huh oh yeah it was like a filing cabinet
you've never seen yeah so one of the
great moments from 2018 as long as we're
doing a review yeah Ronnie's fiancee
Stephanie young beautiful have you met
Stephanie I love Stephanie so much I
feel like she came out of my own car
that's weak mrs. mom one of the great
moments about Ronnie was a fiancee
Stephanie didn't even know he had been
pegged before she heard it on the air
Ronnie had never told Stephanie that he
liked things in his ass here she is
telling us about when she found out okay
let's remember now Stephanie when did
you first find out about this listening
to the show no one came up to you and
said hey Ronnie just confessed that he
took a dildo in his ass and this shocked
Jim it did what was your initial
reaction like were you like [ __ ] I don't
know that he likes that in his ass right
that was exactly my did you think it was
a one-time thing
yes because I'm gonna ask him hey have
you ever stuck a dildo with your ass but
isn't that a great thing
Ronnie cuz it led to her actually
putting some stuff in your ass so it was
good that as long as reviewing weird
moments with Ronnie over the year we
also found that Ronnie got a little too
friendly with our writer Chris Wilding
at the Christmas party remember this I
didn't rub your ass dude you were so
[ __ ] drunk you don't remember what
you did yeah I was hanging out your
boyfriend not you me and my boyfriend my
ex-boyfriend you can you put your ass
right in my crotch and you said you're
gonna you're gonna [ __ ] my ass to my ex
and went to his ass and started
thrusting and said I'm gonna [ __ ] you in
your ass Wow yeah cuz we were joking
around I would just appreciate three god
sakes
oh my god what was that about drunk
what's with Ronnie coming on to dude
he misses with my son [ __ ] [ __ ] his
[ __ ] dog
thank you mrs. Mon there
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]